[Music]
and the mayor of portland oregon is
telling the federal government he
doesn't want its help
after weeks of protests and unrest and
he tweeted the best thing they can do is
stay inside their building or
leave portland altogether joining me now
is dave rubin host of the reuben report
and dave let me read to you a little bit
from
a letter that senators wyden and merkley
have
put forward if we could pull that up on
the screen here so i can
say it's they they said we unequivocally
condemn such acts of violence and any
effort to target attack or silence
those peacefully exercising their first
amendment rights
well i think everyone can agree with
that nobody wants first amendment rights
to be infringed upon but what about
your right to protection
yeah you know dana i'm a simple guy i
don't ask my government to do that much
but one of the things that i do ask the
government to do
is protect life and property so of
course
everybody is for peaceful protesting i
haven't seen anyone across the political
aisle
say that people cannot peacefully
protest what you can't have
is rioting looting creating autonomous
zones places that police officers can't
go that there's some sort of secondary
law enforcement system or or a total
side
set of rules i mean these are the things
that you cannot have
um but you know look this is just
consistent
with what we're seeing pretty much every
progressive
mayor do in every progressive city
whether it's portland or
seattle or some of the things that de
blasio's doing in new york or garcetti
is doing right here in la
and i think the average person you know
they're for protests
they're for the first amendment the
second amendment the bill of rights but
they do
want law and order as to whether the
feds should be in these cities or not
that's an interesting debate which is so
sort of side debate on this and maybe
it's a bit of a trap
that they're springing on trump because
then it'll make him look like an
authoritarian that they want him to
portray
they want to portray him as but people
want law and order it really is that
simple
you know it reminds me back in 2005 at
the lead up to hurricane
katrina when the state and local
governments refused
to evacuate they did not listen to
requests from the federal government to
do that
did not want to have the federal
government come in to help and then
there was a tipping point
when it became obvious that the federal
government had to go in to help
and i know that we don't i know you
don't have a crystal ball
there but i do wonder if you have any
insight
into what the tipping point of this
could be
you know it's almost like you don't want
to say what you think the tipping point
could be because
the tipping point will be mass violence
or or serious amount of death or looting
or or even worse um and then the feds
will
have to come in but i think your your
analogy to hurricane katrina is probably
right in some ways
they have a dereliction of duties here
if you're a mayor not taking care of
your city
and then you're saying oh no now let the
feds do it but by the time the feds have
to come in whether it's a natural
disaster
or a man-made created disaster which
these riots are it's
probably too late and then we have a
whole set of other problems
so look if any progressive mayor is
watching it's like just do your job
protect your streets so that your people
can protest peacefully and you're
protecting your citizens and your law
enforcement
and then let's try to go forward but if
you can't do that you probably shouldn't
be a mayor
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell